we see remarkable responses in ALL. So maybe I'm going to step back. So disease relapse is the
leading cause of death after transplant. And actually, the data presented here are data from
CIBMTR just a decade ago, where we saw that the majority of patients relapse post-transplant
having ALL, and that was the main cause of death. So the question was, at that time, particularly
as biological agents came along, is there something we can do about it? I mean, after
transplant, so that we can modulate this outcome, particularly as post-transplant patients have low
leukemia burden, donor T-cells are present, they were not exposed, maybe for tumor antigen,
and can we prevent relapse? And so blenatumumab came along, obviously, first in relapse refractory
setting. Now, many things have changed, and we are figuring out how to design,
less toxic and most effective therapies for ALL. But kind of thought was that there are multiple
mechanisms of immune evasion after transplant from checkpoint inhibitor upregulation, changes in
microenvironment, novel mutations, but also downregulation of HLA class 2. And actually,
on the right-hand side, I presume, of the slide, you can see some of the in vitro studies showing
the upregulation of HLA class 2.
Following treatment with blenatumumab, and also more efficacy in a lower angle of healthy donor
T-cells, so providing in vitro tumor lysis and proliferation of T-cells in the context of
blenatumumab. So we designed post-transplant blenatumumab study. As everyone knows,
at Hopkins, we are very aggressive about non-myeloblative allogeneic transplant,
and also the other part of our approach,
post-transplant is to stop immune suppression very early on. So in generally, most of our patients
stop immune suppression by day 60. So we felt maybe we can design a study where we are going
to administer blenatumumab at the time as they complete immune suppression and by day 60 and try
to really intervene at the time that most early relapses that are most detrimental occurred.
So the study was designed, classical post-transplant side platform,
and then patients were taken off immune suppression as a part of standard of care on day 60. They
didn't have any evidence of GVHD, and the goal was to give one to two infusions, depending on
MRD status determined by flow, within first 180 days post-transplant. And patients obviously could
not have active GVHD requiring steroid therapy. So 57 patients were consented. We included ALL
and non-Hodgkin lymphoma.
This was more exploratory study. At that time, we didn't have all these affected biologic agents
that we have these days for non-Hodgkin lymphoma. And 42 patients started treatment kind of half
of lymphoma and leukemias. Main reason by screen failures were GVHD in those patients who needed
some extra steroids or tacrolimus beat on day 60. And most patients completed one cycle of treatment.
There were several
patients that didn't complete because of transaminitis, neutropenia, patient preference,
and one patient had early relapse. These are demographics. These are not CR1 just patient.
I would say that majority of patients had more than two lines of therapy, two and more lines of
therapy. Similarly for non-Hodgkin lymphoma, as well as for ALL. And some of them in non-Hodgkin
lymphoma were in advanced CR3, 4, or PR.
But what is important that among ALL patients, 68% did receive blenatumumab and also 10% of
had prior allogeneic transplant. So this was second transplant. So this was bad group of patients. And
there were also mutations associated with more aggressive diseases. So in terms of conditioning
and transplant, majority of patients received reduced intensity conditioning and more than 70%
of patients received less than 70% of patients received less than 70% of patients received less
had haploidentical transplant, but more than half of patients were transplanted with PBSCT,
with pH negative ALL, but for lymphoma, more commonly was bone marrow. What is important to
say is that actually all patients were really able to start this treatment within 130 days,
and practically they couldn't start before day 120 because by stopping immune suppression,
allowing for a period of time that we had to monitor them before they can
be enrolled on the study, this was the period. So I think this was relatively successful.
In terms of toxicity, no major toxicities other than expected neutropenia in some of the patients,
increased liver function tests, and just in the long term, there is always this question of
oblinatumumab. Obviously, there was downregulation of immunoglobulin,
there were approximately 25 patients where we monitored IgG and we ultimately replaced,
but there was no infections or any adverse outcomes related to that.
So these are the survival outcomes. This is at two years, but we have five-year follow-up,
and actually we have 80 and plus more, almost 90% survival rate after two years,
and relapse-free survival, actually I have three years, also has been in the range of 80%.
So...
Moving forward, the main relapses, and I think this is the most kind of coming recurring theme,
what we are hearing here is that all three ALL patients who relapse on this study actually all
relapse in central nervous system. There was no systemic relapses. And for several mental cell
lymphoma relapse also, there were some with the CNS involvement. And they were early relapses,
so I don't know that we can really...
Say how much Blina could improve their outcomes. But in general, now what I'm showing you,
we look recently in our outcomes for patients with ALL divided by the decades when the biologic
agents and Blina tumor were approved versus not. And what we have and we compare in red
is overall survival for the newer decade, and then blue is old decade,
but we can see that there is in general overall survival in our patients with acute lymphoplastic
leukemia post-transplant has been now 72%, relapse-free survival 65%. And actually,
we transplanted sicker and older patients and works comorbidity index here, outcomes are
improved. And I think the only what is attributable is the fact that these patients are now in better
remissions. And this is now for CR1, how I think...
It's another question, what about MRD? And if we are able to successfully eradicate MRD by Blina
tumor these days, and we all give it to patients in CR1 and they go to transplant, these curves are
pretty much getting close to 90% or something in terms of survival. So, I think this is small
study. I think it cannot tell us that should we give to patient Blina tumor or not. And certainly,
I don't have deep MRD.
But I think overall, in designing the future, it's important to see that really these biological
therapies are really eradicating MRD, which actually is transferring to improve outcomes
also post-transplant. I think we will need to learn which patients should be transplanted,
but it's really the pre-transplant therapy that is changing.
What I can say for this study, that this post-transplant Blina was very
feasible and safe. We didn't have any GVHD and did have very nice responses in our patients.
This was not CR1 patients. So, future randomized trial, look at post-transplant Blina versus
observation, but I would really like to look more in the role of MRD in deciding whether we should
intervene. Maybe similar what we have now in AML in terms of FLT3 MRD.
Anyway, thank you for having me here.